[Music]
one of the most valuable things you can
learn in rxjs is how to create custom
operators they will help you reuse
common logic throughout your application
but more importantly you'll understand
how observables work at a more
fundamental level in this video we'll
cover the basics of custom operators
rxjs and if you're a pro member there's
a follow up video about performing joins
and firestore using custom operators if
you're new to the channel I can
subscribe and you can find the source
code at angular firebase comm I like to
think of an rxjs operator as middleware
for an observable stream a chicken goes
in the operator does something and
nuggets come out there are tons of
operators built into rxjs already but
oftentimes you'll have complex business
logic that doesn't fit one of the
generic operators a common use case that
I run into is joining collections and
documents together from the firestore no
sequel database the code to do this is
relatively complex but I can wrap it all
up in a custom operator and reuse it
throughout my application as needed and
I can even do things like state
management air handling custom logging
inside the operator itself now let's go
ahead and jump into the code for this
video I'll be using the blank typescript
project on stack blitz I have installed
rxjs and then I'm writing a function
called log that will simply write the
value that's emitted from the observable
on the screen to the right so we'll use
the of method to create an observable of
the string hello and you can see that
it's logged here in that browser I'm
going to start by creating a more
explicit complex operator and then we'll
break this down to make it more simple
for your more practical use cases an
operator itself is just a pure function
we'll go ahead and create one called to
uppercase and it will just up case the
characters in the string so this outer
function is our operator and then it
returns an inner function that returns
an observable that feels a little
confusing at first but after you do it a
couple times it'll feel pretty natural
the inner function gives you access to
the source observable at that given
point in time so what you can do is
create a new observable by subscribing
to this source observable now there's a
much cleaner way to do this but I just
want to show you how it works at a more
fundamental level
we can have this function return a new
observable that subscribes to the source
observable then we can implement the
next callback with this source
observable and transform it to whatever
value we want to be emitted next in our
case we can just call X dot to uppercase
and that will transform the string to
uppercase then inside this method you
can also implement the error and
complete methods if you want to control
the behavior of those callbacks as well
and that gives us a completely custom
pipeable operator from scratch now we
can put it to use by going down to our
observable of hello and before
subscribing we'll pipe in the to
uppercase operator and as you can see
that transforms the value to uppercase
another thing you might want to do is
pass arguments into your operator let's
go ahead and refactor our operator to
take the emitted value and raise it to
the power of whatever number is passed
in as the argument we'll go ahead and
rename our function to Pio W and in the
first function we can name whatever
arguments are able to be passed into it
then I'll go down to the operator as
it's used in the pipe passing the number
three and then I'll change our
observable to two so basically we're
raising two to the power of three then
this method is already implemented in
plain JavaScript in the math class so we
can just go into next and take the
emitted value and raise it to the power
of n and if we run that you can see it
emits a value of eight and if we change
our argument to 100 you can see it emits
a much larger value so that's pretty
cool but that's a lot of code for not a
whole lot of impact we can simplify this
code dramatically by piggybacking on
existing rxjs operators in a lot of
cases you'll be mapping one value to
another value that's what we're doing
right now with this power function so
let's go ahead and delete this whole
part about creating a new observable and
instead we'll use the existing map
operator from rxjs
as our second function maps already
going to subscribe to the source
observable for us so all we have to do
is return the actual math logic that we
want implemented in this operator much
cleaner and much easier to read and it
works exactly the same way as the
previous operator did a fun exercise is
to combine rxjs with low - they're both
functional libraries and
get a lot done with very little code I'm
going to create a pick numbers operator
and what this will do is filter out any
object properties that have number
values this would take a good amount of
code if you are doing it from scratch
but with lodash we can use that pick by
function then pass the emitted value as
the first argument and then another
lodash function as the second argument
that checks whether or not the property
is a number now if we have an observable
object for example a response from an
HTTP call we can use our custom operator
to filter only the object properties
that we actually want you'll notice in
our object that the bar property is a
string so when we pipe in our operator
it filters that property out from the
emitted value now keep in mind that when
you're creating custom operators you're
not just limited to map you can use any
existing rxjs operator to create your
own custom operator and you could even
use multiple operators together in a
pipe for example if I want to create an
operator that filters only numbers
through the stream I can just use rxjs
filter then pass in that is number
function from lodash now if we have an
observable that we're only expecting to
emit numbers we can pipe in this
operator and filter out anything that's
not an actual number in this case 3 & 4
are strings so we should only get one
two and five emitted from the observable
so now that you know the basics of
custom rxjs operators I want to show you
a more advanced example but first I want
to give a shout out to nicholas jameson
who puts out some amazing content on
advanced rxjs concepts and who is also
an rxjs core team member you should
definitely follow him on medium and
Twitter if you're doing anything with
rxjs
but in this next example we're going to
build an operator that has its own
internal state and uses multiple
built-in rx operators within the custom
operator itself this can be useful when
you have complex business logic within
your stream and also need to share data
between multiple operators and multiple
limited values normally you want to keep
your functions as pure as possible
meaning given the same inputs they
always produce the same outputs so if
you declare a variable inside the
operator and have other operators read
and mutate it you are violating the
principle of peer functions however
there are some very practical use cases
for doing so and we can do it in a way
that's responsible
predictable across all subscribers to an
observable so if you want to share
information between operators you should
first wrap it in defer this is an
observable factory function that will
ensure any state kept in this operator
will happen on a per subscriber this
stream we can declare the stateful
variable inside the defer callback then
all of the operators or functions inside
of it will have the ability to read and
mutate this variable so at this point we
can construct our own custom pipe on the
source observable then the operators can
do whatever they want to the state in
this example we'll just add a new value
to the existing string so we get an
ever-growing string based on each newly
emitted item that's just a trivial
example but in the real world you might
need to share data between multiple
operators and you might need to do more
advanced things like caching API calls
and things like that or you might need
to switch map to multiple related
observables which just becomes really
hard to do in a purely functional way
but in any case the operator we just
built will return a cold observable that
has its own internal state so each
subscriber will get a refreshed state
based on that subscription so I'm
actually going to change history to a
random number just to demonstrate this a
little bit better then we can go and
create an interval and we'll pipe in
this custom operator if we subscribe to
it twice you'll notice that we get two
different random numbers that's because
we're dealing with a cold observable so
they're each creating a new observable
on the subscription so if you want to
make this observable hot and share the
state between multiple subscribers you
can just pipe in the share operator when
creating the observable and then that
state will be shared between all
subscribers so now you can see that both
subscribers are logging the same random
number because they're sharing the same
source and the state still only gets
mutated once even though there's
multiple subscribers in the next video
we'll cover even more advanced concepts
with angular fire - and fire store to
join and merge collections and documents
together
I'm gonna go ahead and wrap things up
there if this video helped you please
like and subscribe and if you want to
take your development to the next level
consider becoming a pro member at
angular firebase comm you'll get access
to my full-length courses as well as a
free book and a whole bunch of other
exclusive content thanks for watching
and I'll talk to you soon